hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of Thrones if you'd like to
watch the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash gamespot but if you
continue to watch here be aware of
spoilers ramsey at this point i mean
like not an episode has gone by where he
hasn't brutally murdered at least one
person this week sadly it was all sure
who got it in the neck you forgot about
well I think it one didn't but I mean it
just kind of feels like they're really
trying to hammer home that like he is
the bad guy he's just rewards are coming
so what's interesting is the theory
going around on the subreddit so
Charlotte a user dan damp spear for
posting this a few days ago but it's
quite interesting to see like Ramses
position in basketball isn't may be as
secure as he thought it would be so we
assume that you know like Ramses got the
superior force he has Winterfell which
is a great defensive position and then
the umbers come round and they just drop
off Rick on right Rick on is there like
the key like linchpin the linchpin of
Ramsey and that's why Ramsey kind of
feel safe that he can move because he
has this like weird alliance with the
umbers whereas this is like a bit of
book background here the umbers are
fiercely loyal to the Starks like that i
think the head of the house gets killed
at the red wedding trying to protect
Robb Stark where is in this they just
just did a complete 180 out of nowhere
seemingly um so it's already a bit weird
anyway there's also some reasoning as to
that that dog's head isn't shaggy dog
when you see that when you watch that
scene again it just sort of like Rick
one doesn't really react he saw it just
goes like you know it doesn't like if
he's he's got a really special bond with
that animal like even seeing its dead
head even if he died like a day or so go
would still be devastating yes i'm
holding out but that's still not shaggy
dog and seriously people on the
subreddit have gone measurements the
whole kind of thing and people are
really convinced that that's not shaggy
dog so by giving Rick on up to ramsey
ramsay now thinks it's safe to leave
Winterfell which is why you no
basketballs get take place outside
mm-hmm but did they know did the umbers
rather
know that the veil will gonna end up
giving their troops to Sansa and John my
friends in the north Tony Sanchez escape
Winterfell I expect he's headed to
Castle black where her brother serves as
Lord Commander but she won't be safe
there not with the Bolton's after her we
should help her that was my instinct as
well because there was a really
interesting theory about like where's
little finger beam has he already like
chatted with the umbers and said I'll
give you the support the troops and
that's why the umbers are sort of
pretending to ally with and that's why
little fingers come back now and been
like hey i just i mean off the top of my
head you want to do this yeah here's a
bird I'm the Lord of umber when he was
talking surrounds the last episode
didn't seem like he enjoyed being there
Wow refuse to take any oaths you refused
to break enough also if osha's been
there the umbers made that buried a big
deal about hating wildlings like
fighting wailings been doing it all my
life but there were too many of them for
us to be back along but she's a wildling
so why didn't they just kill her they
didn't need her anymore they had Rick on
true so do you think this hold any water
I think it's a dangerous strategy
bringing you know the key to the north
or one of the many keys to the north
into the house of someone who stabs
people for fun a lot of the time so I
reckon they've got to have some really
solid plan about what they're going to
do I think it's going to be a beautiful
moment ambassador Bowl if it suddenly
turns out that you know the inside
betrays him so you know we've seen the
troops to ya if he goes outside
Winterfell to go and fight Jon and then
when he turns around there's just all
these humble flags everywhere well
probably stark flags everywhere and he's
like wait a second I love if the umbers
just had sort of like a reversible yeah
I would like Humber's one side in it
yeah mid-battle I love if they just like
pulled like a cord and it just unfurled
like Matilda bathroom until de oh I
can't wait for that if that's not true
it's going to be heartbreaking because I
won't wreck on to be okay recon there
well I got like a little finger
convinced Sansa to like
weds the Bolton's so he might have had
that plan in action all that time you
think you'll go get John be like yo
Sansa's hanging out here we need your
help we've got the umbers on board and
now since Sansa escaped that's kind of
thrown like a wrench into his plans
who's that ok how can I adapt to this ok
we'll use Rick on the only thing is
what's little fingers endgame why is he
doing be the best cuz he is maybe like I
could use reward it just be worn off and
marry Sansa yeah but now he's got John
who's you know I mean little finger
doesn't know that penalties the bastard
so could he be the board of the north
well I've seen that maybe Santa might be
able to legitimize him would that be
beautiful thing is as well like little
finger doesn't know John died so yeah he
still would have had to keep his Nights
Watch oath mm-hmm so he would have been
that would have been a risk he would
still be Lord Commander yeah basically
i'm pretty sure Littlefinger is doing
this for power maybe money probably
Sansa but will it play out for him or
will it play out for the Starks for once
you